- I'm just Jets, Knicks now
'cause the Rangers and Yanks won.
- You jump off winning band wagons?
- That's right I'm an actual
winner in life. Got it.
- That was really fucking mean
to listen to, I was like--
- I know but the best part was
I looked you directly in the face too.
It wasn't even like--
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(all laughing)
God, I'm so bitter, it's unbelievable.
I'm such a happy human but
when I come into contact--
I'm so bitter being here
looking at all the happiness
from all these Patriots' fans.
(thrilling music)
- [Gary Vee] You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(calm music)
- Sonic time?
- Yeah but Sonic brought--
- Uh, D Rock showed it to me,
I really like it.
- Do you see it in real life?
- Yeah, I really like it.
- It's cool, right?
That's it, this is the flag in the ground.
Every single piece of video
content I put out ever again
has that tag up front, period.
So that's that.
- [Man On Video] You
pick one and you do it,
- You know what's cool about it is--
- They touch the goose egg sign, right?
- Yeah.
- You pick one and you do it
and you do it for six months to a year
and if you like where it's
going, you keep doing it.
If not, you take those experiences
and you pick the next
one up, literally right.
- It's gonna be an awesome sticker.
Everyone's gonna do it.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna own it,
I'm gonna write the article right now.
- Smart
- Titled.
- Who came up with it?
- The clip, the audio thing?
- The concept of even doing it?
- Me.
- Yeah?
Yeah, why do you think
think it's getting done?
Why do think it's happening?
I don't know, somebody
could have been like,
"Hey Jamie,
- No, no, no.
- you thought of this?"
- No, no, no,
absolutely, that happens.
- Alright, yeah. Rarely.
- Rarely.
You know it's a great idea.
It's happened.
- It normally goes like this.
You guys have an idea,
three weeks later you guys are like,
"Guys, I have an idea!"
- That's probably exactly right.
By the way, I honestly believe that that's
how everybody works.
- Yeah, I mean
that's human nature.
- You know, like--
- There was one time and I was like bro.
And then we spent like ten minutes on it
and then we finally got there.
- And AJ was right.
I was so pissed.
- I was like bro,
I literally walked you
through this two weeks ago.
(all laughing)
- I got a lot of respect for you.
- Thanks, bro.
- I watch your videos
every fucking day.
- I appreciate that bro,
thank you.
- Here he is here, what's up man?
- How we doing?
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, doing good.
How are you?
- Wanna sit right there?
- What's up bro?
- But there is a place where everybody--
The reason I've been
successful in business
is I'm not emotional in business.
That's why people lose a business.
They make emotional decisions.
I make no emotional decisions
except fucking football.
- That's super emotional.
- Totally emotional.
- Can you teach us some
cool business slang,
like office terms, like I like to say,
"Let's circle back on that".
(audience laugh)
- That's good, can I rate them?
Because I don't even know--
Like I have my own slang,
I don't think I have any.
- Let's put a pin tn that one.
- Good that's like a bee.
- What about net net?
- Love it, hey, hey, hey.
Erika's throwing net net's on us.
Erika's a fucking G.
- Yeah, but the net net thing?
In general but net net is
a super A turn for her.
- [Man] I still don't know what it means?
- It means net net.
- Right, it means
fucking nothing.
(audience laugh)
- I get it. Are you confused
when somebody says, net net?
- No, I just like--
- It means
the bottom fucking line, dick.
- [Man] Why didn't you just
say the bottom fucking line?
- Well 'cause net net means it too.
- [Man] Yeah, I guess so, I don't know
all the buzzwords for office--
- Dude, you live on buzzwords.
- [Man] No I don't, not office buzzwords.
- The foundation of this
whole fucking organization
is buzzwords.
- Yeah, but not
office buzzwords,
- Get it.
- That's like listening--
- We just need to focus
on Banana Land and Mushroom
Factory and everywhere.
Do a deep dives and getting
a 20,000 foot over--
- Are you guys making some stuff
happen down here?
- Oh yeah.
- Enjoy the weekend everyone.
(applause)
- Thank you, real pleasure.
Like I think you know
this, I'm not optimistic.
You can go search eight jet traffics
on YouTube where my brother and I
are booing the fucking result.
Like I'm not optimistic, I've cried
on the announcement of a new head coach
but in this scenario I
am, I think Adam Gase
is going to dominate New York City.
(man laughs)
- I do, I really do. I fully believe it.
- [Man] You're crazy.
- I'm not, I'm not.
You know what the best part about this is?
Here's the best part: the amount of times
I'm gonna clip you doing
that when we win a Superbowl
in your fucking mouth
is gonna be remarkable.
- He said that so many times about me.
- Guess what, I got good news.
I'm not this fucking dude.
Hey bro--
- You're a Jets man.
- I love you, I'm just saying I'm not you.
- We're rooting for the same
fucking thing here.
- Listen, I love you.
- Guess what, we're in
the same fucking boat.
- I know a boat we're in, I
know exactly the boat we're on.
You want me stand up,
straight to the camera?
What's up guys, I'm Gary Vaynerchuk
and I'm ready to answer the internet.
Oh, shit I got to read?
Would you rather have everyone naked
at all times or everyone clothed--
Naked at all times.
- [Man] Yeah?
Even everybody, your grandmother,
old, ugly people, fat people.
- Don't judge people, bro.
Would you rather sit
down with your parents
and watch every sexual
encounter you've had
or watch your parents' sex tape
when they've conceived you.
Sex tape, when they conceived me.
- [Man] Why?
- 'Cause it's the greatest
moment that ever happened.
(everyone laughs)
- Asked to go to the
T-wolves next game with you?
- I filmed it yesterday.
- You did?
- I filmed it.
- The video comes out tomorrow
The video comes out tomorrow.
That's fucking crazy timing
- I got an inside camera
on the dude for the reaction video.
- You did? That's awesome.
Guys thank you so much,
have a great week, man.
Enjoy the game. Thanks, good to see you,
KFC thanks for having my back. See ya.
- [KFC] I will always, always.
- [Garry Vee] For me it's the at-bat.
I think that we are stunningly
lacking the gratitude
of actually being a human
being in the first place.
There's nothing you'll ever accomplish
that is remotely more remarkable that then
that you actually were a human being.
The math is so absurd.
I'm so driven by fucking gratitude,
I can't believe I have a life.
You could have been a fucking tree.
(laughter)
Being dead serious, you
could've been a tree.
Like I just wish people understood,
One of the things I tell
people all the time is,
you know right now we're
living through an amazing era
of putting youth on a pedestal
because of technology right?
These last 10, 15 years is like
the 20 year old is on, right?
I'm 43.
When, you were 20 and
you went into a business,
you did dumb shit for 10 years
like intern and like get the coffee.
Now kids come into businesses
and like they're put on a pedestal
because they understand technology.
So right now in our society
the last 10, 15 years,
we've put youth on a pedestal.
I'm completely convinced
that the counter to this
and what I'm watching is
that we're gonna put wisdom
and age and experience on a pedestal next.
So I think for all the 75
to 99 year-olds out there,
your era's next and I'm
being serious about this.
I would tell you the amount of people here
that would massively benefit from going
and volunteering for five
hours at a retirement home
and having two meaningful conversations
with somebody 80 or older
that is not somebody you're related to.
And if you understood and listened
and watch their energy,
you would understand
how lucky we are to have
our years ahead of us,
how much you don't want to live life
based on trying--
You need to be in a place
where you don't regret
the things you didn't do, you know?
I just think we lack perspective
and I think we talk a lot about privilege
of like right now thank
God, race and gender
and we're having that conversation.
We're not having that
conversation around ageism, right?
We're finally starting
to have some decent level
of a conversation of
trying to have empathy
for different backgrounds, race,
things of that nature.
But I'm telling you the
biggest lack of perspective
in this room, is how young
everybody in this room is.
People are anxious and insecure
because they haven't
accomplished something
and they haven't even gotten out of
the fucking first quarter.
So I highly recommend you realize
that you've got a fuckload
of years in front of you
and slow it the fuck down, thank you.
(applause)
What did he just say?
That can't be real, that can't be real.
My heart just broke.
That better not be real,
that can't be real.
- Dave said it went through.
- K man--
Hold on, why? That can't be real.
AJ?
- AJ left.
What the fuck?
(indistinct chatter)
MVP baby, how are you?
Been looking forward to
meeting you, brother.
Been looking forward to meeting you.
It's a real pleasure, man.
I've been a fan of your
work for a long, long time.
- I actually went looking for you one time
'cause a friend of mine
sent me some of your stuff
and I was like, man this
guy thinks just like I do
and then I saw the video
where you were pulling
out the action figures.
I wanna introduce you to my daughter.
This is Lexi.
- Hi, it's nice too meet you.
- How are you?
I know what it is, I know what it is.
- Hey, get over here.
- [Man] Look at him,
oh he's hit with a DDT.
- Now you're doing one for me.
This one, this way, this is mine.
- [Man] One, two...
- I can't believe they
fucking traded Porzingis.
I'm so fucking pissed, fuck, fuck!
I fucking hate this franchise.
This better fucking
mean that Anthony Davis
is coming here and that's
the back end of this.
- Congratulations, man.
- Thank you.
- I'm proud of what you doing
- I appreciate that.
I just don't understand
that fucking trade at all.
I'm glad you guys were here.
Thank you, I'll see you tomorrow night.
This is catastrophic like
just an atrocious, fucking
ridiculously stupid deal.
I'm fucking dead, fuck.
- What's going on?
Dead.
I'm dead, I'm just dead.
Like we finally have a fucking moment,
there's something somewhat interesting
because we trade to keep KP and I'm dead.
There's all sorts of good content
and D-rock's got the camera down!
How many times do you want me
to say fucking arbitrage,
like Jesus Christ
we finally have something.
KP is gonna be the
top-five player in the NBA,
I just want it right in our mouths.
How the fuck are the two
best players undrafted--
My team's drafted the last 20
fucking years of Revis and KP.
What happened is you got
emotional people making
emotional decisions.
What are you laughing that
there's no content now?
- No, I was reading the text message.
- No, the content's gone,
D-rock, you missed the moment.
- It's so common.
(D-rock laughing)
No, it is vlog.
I put out all sorts of neat
stuff that you've never seen
'cause D-rock's always weirdly
like, had the camera down
when we had finally something interesting
like a real unique moment that
we could have looked back in 35 years.
- That's true, you could have captured
the most disastrous moment
in Nexsport's history
- And yet you didn't.
And really what the big question is,
is what were you doing?
(laughing together)
- Ty, Ty, you know that
GIF where the guy's like--
- That one, I love that GIF.
- Got all these emotions and excitement.
- You gotta play that
GIF if you edit this in.
That GIF is magic.
- In fucking Atlanta with a
bunch of fucking Patriot fans
making fun of the Knicks.
Fuck.
- [Woman On Video] For a lot of people,
they're scared to raise their--
- What's that?
- Let's not do that again.
- No, but it wasn't a great video.
No?
- No.
- And it wasn't your
fault, I was okay with it
because I knew that it
couldn't get, like--
You had to really actually do a mix
of the funniness of that
call, it's a much better--
Could have done a carousel
and it probably would have done well.
- You did the carousel.
- Got it.And did it do well?
- No.
- Got it.
- You know what else doesn't look good?
This fucking train!
How long's this been?
(calm music)